es ist wichtig auch zukünftig hier zu
sein nämlich so lange sollen die eu
außengrenze nicht ordentlich bewacht
wird und wird deshalb diesen nationalen
grenzschutz brauchen ich glaube hier
geht es um zwei signale die ganz klar
ausgesendet werden zum einen nach außen
hin zu schlepper und zur schlepperei
hier in österreich wird kontrolliert und
hier gibt es kein durchschlüpfen ich
habe auch immer mehr soldaten und dann
auch sprechen können heute hoch das
netzwerk also sie sind sehr motiviert
trotz der rückläufigen zahlen nicht
klappe zum einen ist der einsatz kommen
durchaus schöner
zum anderen wissen sie auch um die
wichtigkeit und ich bin sehr froh dass
wird diese enge kooperation auch mit der
polizei leben wo wir vielleicht auch
über diese scans modell für die
eu-außengrenze zumindest temporär
entsprechend nachdenken und vielleicht
lösungen finden